she wrote a relationship book and I want
to get to this oh yeah I do my homework
any sessions it's it's hard to fight
naked this is a relationship book you
wrote called it's hard to fight naked
and it is why did you call it what's the
title mean well I mean it's literally
and figuratively hard to fight naked and
I know it's true you know and I tell
people and you know I'm some of the
advice I give in the book is that if a
conversation starts to get too heated
you know as a woman I take off my shirt
and put lotion on my elbows and the man
if you say you're talking you're having
an argument the man you take your shirt
off right okay any man my husband V
you're arguing about a parking ticket
yes that is what I that is part of the
some of the advice in the book that was
not the original title you wanted it's
hard to fight naked you wanted a
different title yeah the original title
for this book guys and gals was a
stomach full penis empty a woman's guide
to a happy marriage
[Applause]
look I just went back in time I I left
my body so that is that you say that
real advice that you would give is that
something that you really believe
[Applause]
you